Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich.
Radiolab is supported by Spotify and everybody knows it's the place to stream
the latest music and podcasts.
Just open the app on your mobile device or desktop.
Click on the browse channel and click on the podcast section.
Stream your favorites across news, entertainment, sports, and culture,
and starts streaming right now.
Wait, you're listening.
No. [inaudible]
you are listening to radio lab, Radiolab
from [inaudible], W N y. S. C e
n n p. R. Re one.
Let me know, propose that I'll never count backwards again.
I'm serious. Hey, I'm Chad at boom rod. I am Robert Pillory. This is radio lab,
the podcast.
And today on the podcast a story about a friendship really cause in almost any
friendship, there'll be a moment where you look across it.
This person you think you know very, very well,
and he or she will suddenly say something or do something or think something
that just throws everything into question. Everything up in the air.
You think of what will you at.
This is a friendship with a big fat what in it?
And the guy that's going to tell us the story is, uh,
Andy Mills and I am a freelance radio producer and the other guy,
you meet him in a minute. So maybe we should just like how did you meet Mike?
What was the, where did you lay eyes on each other? Well,
it was my sophomore year of college and it was the time that the freshmen are
all moving into the dorms and I was meeting new people welcoming the freshman.
Oh, you're an ra or you're some sort of no, no,
just one of those chatty a people in the dorm and you're like, what's your name?
Exactly. And as I was talking actually to a group of freshmen in my room,
I hear this like strange noise from the room next door.
There's this kind of low drone.
So I kind of peeked over and saw,
you know,
18 to 19 year old kid in a wheelchair,
dark curly hair.
And um,
this noise I had been hearing was his voice.
Not even a week later I run into him in the hallway and I introduced myself.
I say, hi, I'm Andy,
what's your name? And he said,
my name is Colin. Ah,
mu. Hey Yo. [inaudible]
con Ashmore Con Ashmore. Yeah,
I was on the way to eat lunch and I invited him to join me.
We sit down in the corner and I noticed like he brings the fork to his mouth,
like really slowly everything about him is, is slowed down,
but also noticed like he's witty, observant.
And so at a point in the conversation I asked him
what's wrong? Like, why, why do you move and talk so slowly?
You just asked him flat out. Yeah. Was He offended?
Yeah,
no, I think he was,
he was relieved to find somebody who was willing to admit that it's a little bit
weird. Yeah. And then he tells me this story
tool. He started at the beginning
[inaudible] 10 he said I was eight years old.
Oh, sorry. Oh was, yeah. In the
[inaudible]
I had this dog, the dog had run off, Bro.
Couteau is Jane.
I ran out into the street and
the next thing I knew I was waking up from a coma. Yeah.
Five one five months later, he got hit by a car. Yeah.
And when you woke up, what did that be to you? What,
what were the injuries that you suffered?
Well,
I could [inaudible] I could move
and then he comes out of it slowly and slowly. But thing is he,
he stays low. Whoa. Slow.
Very slow. So this is a man who is slowed down globally, right?
Except for, of course his mind. Hmm. Really? Oh yeah, he does well in school.
He's smart. He has a great sense of humor.
And we connected, you know,
I was his neighbor in the dorm and we had a lot in common,
like a lot of the same music used to stay up late.
I'd play my acoustic guitar and he would sing matchbox 20 songs from the 90s.
You know, he would you, uh, do you, you must slow down your playing.
Is that my playing is not exactly a rockstar material or anything.
I love that song. I think,
I know it wasn't long before we ended up having these really deep conversations
in the middle of the night, but what, well,
the fact that both of our parents are divorced and how we both grew up in
households that were fighting all the time and having to sleep at grandma's.
Is it like a regular part of both of our lives?
Kahn's parents started fighting a lot after he came out of the coma.
The mom blamed the dad for not watching con and yeah,
we talked a lot about how like that impacted our life growing up and we just
became really close to level situation.
Tell me what you had for breakfast today. You know,
I've known Khan for almost a decade. Um,
but it wasn't until last summer that I decided to interview con on tape and it
was in the middle of this interview that Khan tells me this story that changed
the
way that I think about Khan and his slowness. So,
um, the story starts off with him in junior high.
First big crush Julie, her name was Julie,
and he's trying to think of something romantic to do to catch your attention.
Oh, and he really loves music.
He was listening to his Walkman one night and he realized that that's,
that's what he wants to do. He would make her
tape a romantic mixtape and that would be the thing.
So he makes this tape and then he decided that [inaudible] Taj soon to actually
sing. Oh, I'm so a love song to Julie.
So he writes the song records,
it puts the tape back in the Stereo and
[inaudible]
my thing whole
[inaudible] he felt embarrassed. He felt confused, screaming,
crying. Wait. Why? Well,
it turns out that was the first time that he had ever heard his voice.
The way that you and I hear his voice. And so wait, first time,
what does that even mean? He never heard a recording of himself or, oh no,
he had, not only had he never heard of recording of himself, but when he talks
you march, help
girl hear you. What do you mean by that,
Lord? I mean,
he tells me that he actually didn't know that his voice was slow.
How's that even possible? I mean,
does that mean his brain is speeding up his voice but not yours? Yeah,
he hears me talk normal and then he hears himself talk normal as well.
Like you think he's slow in speeding up or do you think he just thinks he's
regular? It's not like he speeds both of us. Doesn't mean that your,
your voice just or his voice just feels normal or does he mean it actually
sounds, it sounds exactly the same.
This one I'm saying like he thinks he sounds here right now.
He would hear you talk, you hear me talk.
Then he would say something and then his head,
it's all the same speed but that doesn't make sense cause it's like variable
speed, you know? I don't think he's, no, I think he thinks he's just normal.
I'm normal inside. So we went back and forth,
back and forth on this and until finally this,
we need a specialist at this point. Yes, we will take our positions there.
Ready. We ended up calling this guy who we've had on the show before. All right,
so Andy orange here, or in Devinsky neurologists. NYU Medical Center.
He's the doctor. Hi. Hi. Oren does Orrin does or know anything? I know.
Yeah. I listen. I'm college educated. I mean,
not this. Anyhow, Andy ran them through the whole story. Yeah. Um,
well he was eight years old and he was a belief. I leave.
I always think you've just heard. And here was the orange reaction. Yeah.
So I guess I, you know, just, it's, it's a fascinating case.
And my first clinical question would be, did he know he moved slowly,
but absolutely. Yeah.
But it was only for his own voice that he was unaware that he was different than
everybody else. Right. So he does have feedback on himself.
The one area he's not getting feedback on is his voice production, which,
which interestingly happens in post encephalitic Parkinson's patients.
They're slow in all their movements. They're slow getting up out of a chair,
they're slow walking. But as with con,
there are some cases where they just get little focal areas that they don't see
their slowness. So Oliver Sacks, when he took care of his awakenings,
patients at Beth Abraham hospital in the Bronx would sometimes record their
voices and play it back and they'd say, that's not me. You're,
you're fiddling with the tape machine.
That's not my voice because the voice to them would sound too slow. Too slow.
Too slow. Yeah, that's exactly. Do you think his inner voice,
his inner mental speed is truly as fast or as that also?
Oh, it's absolutely normal. Okay. Khan and I both went to a Christian college.
We both made an exodus from that kind of fundamentalist Christian world at
around the same time, which involved, uh, you know,
long talks about what we believe and what we think we might believe next.
And there was never a point where I was having to like,
wait for Khan to make some, you know,
mental exercise before you'd respond.
And those are some pretty complex things dealing with faith.
What I don't understand fully is why he hears you,
Andy speaking at three times his pace and feel your normal,
but something about his own voice feeding back to his own brain.
He never perceived that at a different speed than your voice in everyone else's.
Do you then trust [inaudible]? Do you wonder about maybe,
would you suspect that if you met him, you'd learn something different than you?
Yeah, no. In medicine you should always trust the patient's report,
but keep in the back of your head a drop of skepticism.
But my gut as a clinician is more than 95% it's real.
Now, keep in mind that was on a true clinical diagnosis.
That was just Orrin Devinsky giving us his gut opinion. What? I have a theory.
I have a theory. Unscientific though it may be. Well that's,
that's what we specialize.
I think that it has something to do with familiarity.
Like when I first met con and I heard his voice,
it was so foreign and so strange and I,
and I could hardly make out what he was saying, but now I'm,
I'm surprised when people say, what did you just say?
And I think what he just said, he's horrified you. I interest, I'm,
I've grown so familiar to his voice that it is it sort of like going into a
Shakespeare play in an act one scene, one acquisitions.
You don't know what's going on.
But somehow in the second act two begins to click. Exactly.
It's that familiarity. And if I have it, I mean, imagine what he must have.
Yeah.
Oh, hi. Cruel. No
dumb toe
hearing. So being present.
But what I don't get is like, we just went on for years. So how, how,
could note how come no one told him his parents and his siblings and his friends
have never turned him into, hey, what, you know, come on, speed it up.
They've never ever said that. No. His parents being deaf, you know,
crossed them out. They couldn't have told him. His parents are deaf,
both of them.
[inaudible] and Khan thinks that everyone else just assumed that he knew what
his own voice sounded like. Really?
Like when you talk to him, to his friends. Hey Hayley. Hey, hello? Hey Dave.
What's up? Oh, not much with the band. I mean,
and you told them the whole thing. What was their reaction? Honestly,
most of them didn't believe me. You're kidding. Huh? Did you know this at all?
No, I had no idea. I didn't know that. And so his, when he speaks,
he just thinks that it sounds just like anyone else. Yeah,
that's what I'm telling you.
That's so sad. Yeah.
[inaudible] so after he found out about his voice,
which I guess was the one thing he thought was normal, um,
what did he do well, he said,
I'm never boot gun talk again.
Um,
did he, did he talk again? Obviously he did. Right?
Well that's the same question I asked him.
After you heard that you were different,
how long did you go before talking again? And he told me,
are you
going back to Google?
And he, he doesn't recall like the first conversation exactly that he had,
but he thinks that was something like,
sure. Uh, Pan
[inaudible] hello.
He didn't want to talk,
but gradually he realized that he kind of had to. Hmm.
And what about singing? He said he, he liked to sing.
Well eventually he got comfortable again with the idea of having his voice
recorded, his singing voice recorded. And so after the interview was over,
he mentioned the song that he actually had been singing a lot and so I turned
the recorder back on and asked if he would sing it for me. So
tell me name of the song
and then just the same way the series,
Huh?
Good.
I [inaudible] by day mean ice,
Huh?
Right. All right.
Then here a full salad on the
Po. Hey, no girl, girl.
[inaudible]
it was actually pretty emotional first both day.
And as I'm sitting there hearing him sing this song,
Hey, I'm just wondering like what does this sound like in his head? Right.
So after I got the tape recorded,
I brought it back to my friends in Chicago and a band called Hudson branch and
all of them know Khan because John and I asked them like,
do you think that we could maybe play some music to this?
So the music could kind of give us a peak into the way the con hears it and the
way the con feels written. Maybe we could feel it too.
[inaudible]
well, all right here.
Sorry, Dawn. The [inaudible]
[inaudible]
good. Hey. Hey.
Hmm.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
great.
[inaudible]
Huh? What did Khan say when he heard it, by the way?
Did it remind him of anything like what he feels? Yeah, I mean,
when he heard it he said, hell yes.
Yeah, no, he loves it.
Thanks to producer Andy Mills, who just received a,
an award at the third coast festival for a shorter version of that piece,
and thanks also of course, to Khan Ashmore and the mayor. Yeah.
Andy m met bold Jacob Bowl, Corey beaner, Coby bean, beaners, Becky Bailey,
he not Kim, they call themselves Pachin branch.
Becky joined them out to be bold, bold, meaner, and meaner. Can Bailey, right?
You know, Hudson branch could be the name of, or a rock band.
That's also a law firm. Anyhow, you can find out more about
them@radiolab.org or@thehutsonbranch.com I Rubber Krulwich Jab Rod,
and thanks so much for listening.